[Music]
my name is eris i am the co-owner of all
together leather and i have been a
professional leather worker for five
years altogether leather is canada's
first queer owned cobbling shop today
i'm going to walk you through how are
your store a faded and poorly re-dyed
your handbag this is our client's
handbag she brought it in because she
had previously tried to re-dye it at a
different shop that did not strip the
dye properly when you look at this bag
you can see that it is gray the handles
are poorly warped and chipped
[Music]
this dior bag is leaking dye and so we
are going to have to deglaze it to start
we will need to prep this bag by taping
off all portions that we do not want to
get dye on to strip the bag we will
start by putting on our safety equipment
deglazer is a very strong chemical that
is formulated to remove sealant coats
and previous dye layers from leather
we will deglaze the bag by going in
small circles with a medium rough sponge
to get the previous dye off in the
previous ceiling coat off
we need to evenly distribute the
deglazer over the bag to ensure that the
dye will evenly go back into the bag
after the fact
we're using a professional oil tan dye
formulated for leather it is better than
alcohol-based dyes as it gives a more
even coverage
we will be using a paint brush for all
of the quilted areas to make sure we get
the creases and wool dauber for the
bottom where it is even leather
we are using a large flat crystals
paintbrush to make sure that our strokes
are wide and even making for a uniform
color
interiors of bags pose challenges
because you are not able to dye liners
and so you have to make sure that you
don't hit the liner which is why we
protect it with tape
the handle's edges are too badly cracked
to be restored and the handles
themselves are bleeding so much dye that
we do not think we can successfully
prevent dye complaining out of them in
the future we are going to remake them
instead
to remove these handles i am going to
pop these rivets using strong sharp side
cutters and bolt cutters
to make the leather strap i'm going to
cut a piece of leather
put it through my bell skyver which is a
machine that thins leather out
glue that piece and wait for that to dry
and then fold that piece over onto
itself
i am going to use a seam roller to fold
these edges to make sure that they
become uniform and even in a new strap
to remake these handles i will be using
an italian calfskin leather in the same
grain as the original bag
i am going to use the old handle as a
stencil on my leather to make sure the
shape stays the same
i am going to trace the base of the
handles onto a leather a leather board
for structure and a top layer of leather
[Music]
i'm then going to glue them all together
making sure that no air bubbles are in
the glue
to make even clean edges we are going to
use an exacto knife and a corner punch
i'm going to sand the edges of these
handles to make sure that they are
perfectly even so that when i put on my
edge coats no burrs or bumps are shown
to put on the edge coat i'm going to be
using a roller ink well and a roller pen
to make sure it is evenly distributed
to place the handle to the strap i will
be using some double-sided tape to
ensure it does not move while i sew it
i'm going to be sewing this handle
together using an industrial walking
foot machine which evenly pulls leather
along to make sure the stitch lengths
are all the same
now i am going to apply an acrylic
leather sealer to ensure that the dye
does not leak onto the customer and to
also waterproof the bag
[Music]
now we are going to use a leather punch
and a leather rivet setter tool to punch
a hole into the handles and to put
rivets through and set them
to finish the bag i'm going to remove
all the tape
and then buff it using a true horsehide
brush which will even out the shine and
the gleam of the back
our customer was thrilled with the end
result of this bag she is extremely
happy to have her handbag back in her
wardrobe
[Music]